welcome back to on base live in your
bleach Report app I am your host Mookie
Betts and today we got Mr Jazz so here
I'm looking here Jazz Chisholm from the
Miami Marlins and I'm looking here
and I see
your uh your whole name
can we skip that part
no not yet we can't skip it just yet and
so for those out there
who don't know
Jazz has a I would say a rather
long name isn't it five or six tapes one
two three four six yeah and juniors at
the end so that means your daddy got a
long name too yeah
so can can we can you say your whole
name do I have to say or you could try
and say it all right I'll try go ahead
Jazz Rado okay
Prince there we go
Hermes there we go
Arrington
Arrington Arrington yeah Chisholm
Junior yes so is that it's actually
really good nobody ever gets it like
first try thank you okay so is that
normal in
in the Bahamian culture not at all like
I I think my grandma just was going
through something and like she named all
her kids like her oldest son is the only
one with like a name that someone else
in this world has so like the other four
none of them have the same like and are
they so did they name their you know I
guess your cousins do that yeah we got a
couple of juices okay
long I just say you very unique
okay a unique name okay so when you were
going to fill out your form to go to
school or whatever it is like jazz just
Jazz yeah Josh Chisholm Junior I always
put the Junior though and they didn't
need the other names no okay all right I
just had to ask
so you uh I'm an All-Star last year
been balling been this year been playing
well obviously
um you know we talked a little bit and
you feel like you could be a little more
consistent or play a little bit better
but that's part of the Beast of baseball
that you will learn you're still young
so yeah you'll you'll learn it there's
no way to skip through any of uh
anything at all in baseball yeah and I
think you're starting to learn that a
little bit oh yeah so so we'll talk
about we'll get into that so we got a
game called on base off base and out you
know what that is so first first thing
is singing out loud singing a song out
loud that you're listening to in your
headphones are you on base or off base
on that on base your own that's that's
the thing you do yeah so do you have the
big headphones or the or the airpods it
depends what I'm doing if I'm taking
ground balls or fly balls in the
Outfield or hitting in the cage I'll put
on my small headphones so you got the
small headphones and you're singing out
loud yeah while taking ground balls or
whatever it is yeah
so you do you you don't do you always
listen to your music while you while
you're doing it uh I like I would like
to but sometimes like when you're
working with your hitting coach and you
need to talk like we need to actually
work on something instead of like oh I'm
already feeling good so we just getting
in the cage and getting that work in to
get ready for the day like that's when
I'm like I'm bumping my stuff because
I'm already like on but like if I'm not
on
I got them out we talking about what
we're doing walking through it so you
don't want nobody else to be bumping
with you that's why I sing out loud oh
so you're the okay got it so that you
don't want them hearing the music you
want them hearing you I mean not really
I mean like I sing out loud because like
in our clubhouse everybody loves music
but not everybody listens to the same
music but everybody will join in on
someone else's music okay so y'all have
concerts together yeah everybody has a
concert nice okay like even the Spanish
yeah y'all got a nice group of oh yeah a
mixed group of guys yeah and everybody
just joins in Joins in it don't matter
that's what I'm talking about so what
what's a good what would be your uh
go-to karaoke song My go-to
oh
for me I like my Spanish boy so I like
to sing like te bote you know you know
yeah I know oh you know you know most of
those do you know Spanish uh you just
know that song no you know Spanish yes I
would say I'm kind of fluent I wouldn't
say completely fluent but like my
grandma my grammar is a little messed up
but I know probably most of the words
and okay and that song is just in
general in general okay so okay all
right we're gonna make sure you know go
do your thing you know you just
remembered the song and then how you
flew in Spanish
all right so next thing
the Home Run sculpture sculpture
sculpture
is should still be inside of
Marlin stadium yes you you're on you're
on base yeah okay I agree with that why
did can you tell do you know why they
moved well they moved it outside well
you know Jeter was our owner at a point
I think Jeter moved it outside
um and you know jitter's not with the
flashiness yeah he just put like a
normal Little M up there now you see it
like yeah but that's like kind of boring
I feel I feel like
it was dope inside oh yeah I wish it was
still there yeah because so can you sign
a position to to I'm actually going to
start one today just because you said
that I feel like around a league the
boys want to see the fish going back and
forth no that's that's I think that's
lit yeah I agree I agree so okay now the
next thing you'd rather play with pigs
that swim
than with dolphins in the in the Bahamas
which one would you rather do it depends
who you are and if you have any metal in
your body
okay so I'm who I am so or you know what
you have metal in your body I don't have
metal in my body
no I'm missing uh so anyways
I don't have any men on my body so let's
just say
[Music]
um
I think I would I think I would go
Dolphins because they they swim and I'm
not sure about pigs that's what I was
saying like like what does the metal
have to do do with with being you'll die
from a dolphin if like that's when a
dolphin becomes more dangerous than a
shark
what does the metal have to do with
anything because of the vibrations
that's how they like you know
no I don't so I'm from the Bahamas so we
learn a lot about animals in the water
right like that's our main thing I feel
like over here you guys learn about more
land creatures yep like but us we're
more like in the water right so like the
metal if you have metal in your body it
like messes with the dolphins like
vibration in their brain and stuff and
that's how they really communicate so
like they're gonna attack you because of
that because you messing up I'm trying
to talk
they're trying to talk it's just like
they're gonna it's gonna mess with the
vibration so they're just gonna think
like you're an enemy right off the and
they come you're coming straight
headbutt you like and if you ever got in
your body so what if you what what if
you had necklaces you would take it off
before you get in the water I don't
think so that's why I said like me I
don't have no metal in my body I'm going
to dolphins so
have you swam with pigs yeah I've seen
it seems nasty
but what you know is it it's not a nasty
I know it's a thing though because I
went to the Bahamas and they say oh you
want to swim with the pig yes I've said
no every single time but why you scared
because of it no I mean I just
would rather not be next to pigs you
know I don't know I have nothing I mean
it's not as bad as it seems so I mean
what they they swim normal they just be
on the beach and they're in the water
they're floating around like they're
just chilling bro they're pigs that
could swim and uh these the like normal
people yeah
so like the the pigs in the in the farm
like they swim yeah they can swim wow
yeah
guys pigs real they can't fly but they
can swim that's true so okay what about
the eating fast food during the season
oh on base off base
see I look like this so I can say on
base okay so you can say yeah I can say
you eat fast food I eat fries
McDonald's fries oh McDonald's fries
okay yeah that's fast food but I mean I
only get the fries yeah that's fine it's
still fast food what wow I mean I could
go and get McDonald's fries and then go
to the Jamaican restaurant and get rice
with oxtail and everything I just want I
just wanted fries
okay I still think it falls on the fast
food but I mean hey what about you I'm
not a bad I I I I do like the most I
would do is probably I guess Chick-fil-A
is fast food right you eat Chick-fil-A
fries yeah I eat Chick-fil-A so you eat
fast food yeah like but that's as bad as
fast as it's gonna get I don't even eat
Chick-fil-A you don't eat Chick-fil-A I
don't really like it like that like I
don't like fast food like that yeah
because it's not your culture yeah it's
not my thing I like rice and stuff like
that did you see about uh tell me about
when Jake Berger I think he head off hit
a walk or walk off home or something
Burger King did something for him how
was that oh yeah can you tell me about
that yeah so we walked in and everybody
had like the burger the Burger King
crowns on there on the chair but he had
like 35 45 Burgers on top of it it's
like I think it was his number 36
Burgers okay yeah on his chair when he
walked in and then they just started
handing them out to everybody did you
eat one I actually I'm a team player so
I did yeah you gotta sometimes you just
gotta wear it you gotta wear it you know
I took all the pickles everything off of
it just like take like a few bites do
the rest in the trash but like that's
cool though did you know did you know
Burger King was founded in Miami no I
did not a fun fact so today
the viewers have learned that pigs can
swim yeah Burger King was founded in
Miami bahamians found Miami did you know
that
three things three things
this is a very informational shelving
I'm very happy you came on here Mr Jazz
Rado oh man all right for the next week
let's let's uh let's switch gears a
little bit you were on the cover of the
show
tell me about that like how did that
come about when you found out you're
going to be on the cover of the show I
heard that you threw your dog
in the pool oh and well he landed in the
pool he landed in the pool up in there
dog probably didn't deserve that he
loves the pool though oh okay okay I
thought you just dogged and he was he
was just sitting down laying down
chilling he was like in my life he's
small he's small okay okay the little
ones in my life and we were just outside
chilling the little one was in my lap
the big one is on the ground I'm not
picking up the big one like he just
jumps in the pool okay so y'all went I
mean they went though they went yeah so
I'm not that big of a pool guy all right
so tell me about it so tell me about it
when you find out you're gonna be on the
show yeah whatever like what was going
through your mind bro it was just like
bro I literally was talking about this
all year like this is crazy like and I
didn't even get to play the whole year
last year like all I did was get to the
All-Star Game and like became All-Star
and like
really for me it was like dang like
that's is that all it takes to get there
and I like honestly like me being real
with myself I thought last year was
trash too even though it was 60 games
like I think I'm only at 60 games this
year and have the exact same numbers so
like when I think of it it's still like
trash to me because it's like
if I can just stay healthy and keep
playing
you can get a lot more out of just that
you know I mean like even though this is
like a dream come true
like in my head it's just like wow I
didn't even play well last year you know
you're on the cover and I'm on the cover
so
I just feel like there's a lot to take
out of that you know for me and so
who do you have you gotten to talk to
like
someone about staying healthy or the
process of of taking care of your body
and all those type of things like have
you who do you talk to about that well
like I've I've talked to a couple guys
and like you know it's just like bro you
just gotta eat right and do this and
then like I have a chef now right this
year I got a chef
probably I only drink
probably juice in the morning but the
rest of the day just water and I still
get got hurt the same amount of time so
like now after like hearing like just
eat healthy and drink water all day like
what else is there to do like I do my
rehab after the game I get in the gym
before the game you know I do I'm doing
everything that I'm supposed to do but
for some reason I'm still getting hurt
this year so like now I'm on that sense
of like what is it really to stay
healthy is it just not going 110 every
day or giving that 100 that you have
that day instead of trying to push it to
your normal 100 you know what I mean I
would say I would say being that I've
been around for a little bit and trying
to say you're old
I'm just playing with you
um I would I would say you're doing the
right thing as far as investing in your
body so the chef right and then a couple
years ago I hired a PT not everybody can
do that yeah I can't afford that right
but I did and so that's that's one thing
but
I think on the field wise I think you
just have to kind of understand
your spots because when I was young
I kind of did some things similar to you
like I would play play the game hard now
that I don't play the game hard now but
like when the ball goes up in the air
I'm going to catch it yeah right well
now the last time I went to catch this
ball that
was around the wall I was concussion out
for two weeks okay so then another time
I hurt my shoulder I was out for out for
two weeks
so understanding that
that one out
could put you out put the team at a
deficit and put you out for a month
I'm pretty sure
the pictures would be like hey just let
that one hit the wall get it and throw
it in then you going now if it's if it's
if it means something you know we're in
the playoffs this any other Go Get It Go
Get It Right but you're playing we're
playing 162 games yeah
and you gotta understand like
the risk versus reward
now if it's the eighth inning you need
to go get it you may have to go get it
yeah right but just if it's the sixth
and you're y'all are five nothing like
let it hit the wall and you talked I
learned this by talking to the pictures
now I didn't I did not just say you know
what I'm just not gonna play hard that's
not what happened yeah
it took me getting hurt
a few times
to then saying okay I want to play
tomorrow too and then I want to play
all the rest of the games and I think
your teammates would say they want you
to play too so you can talk to them and
and see I've heard it from a few
pictures I ain't gonna lie like my last
time getting hurt when I ran into the
wall they're like
trust me like because I was out for like
a month and a half two months
uh because of my toe I broke my toe
and they're just like you ain't gotta go
to the wall everyone not every single
time I think that was like my fourth
time running into a hallway yeah and it
was like only the second month in the
season like right you crazy for running
to that wall like that bro I was getting
used to the Outfield so it was just like
bro I see it go up I guess yeah I see it
go up and I bro like I've ran down so
many balls this year right but you
playing Marlins stadium yeah
when you go to Dodger Stadium you can't
do that oh no it's not you turn around
and you take eight steps you're at the
wall yeah
I'm so happy I figured that out before I
got to Dodger Stadium yeah there you go
and so but now you unders now that's
what it takes to play 162 games
to to be who you want to be like you
said at the beginning of the show you
still feel like it was trash yeah well
it don't matter how good you are if you
ain't playing
that's a fact you know what I'm saying
so most important thing is I
don't I'm not saying take it easy though
that's that's no that's what I don't
want to be misconstrued I'm not saying
dog at this any other but I am saying
I'm trying to play the whole season too
yeah so you you know and you'll get it
bro you'll get it speaking of
you know the boys want to want you to
play everybody wants you to play because
you just uh look at you
you hard you know what I'm saying you're
hard so so
you got the Little Euro Step when you
hit homers
you know you are
going I'm not saying going against
baseball culture but you're like
expanding the culture bringing bringing
culture to the game
and so
where did that come from does that come
from being in the Bahamas your love your
your passions that how you show your
love your passion like what where did
that come from
that's what I feel like it was for me
because like all my favorite players
weren't like
I mean I guess they were other people's
favorite players too when I was gonna
give me give me a couple favorite
players like Griffey bonds canoe like
I would say like Jim Edmonds like the
swings and the guys that really like
admired their swings like Josh Hamilton
and those guys like
they didn't really like everybody really
hated the way that they acted on the
field yeah like you know what I mean
like when griffy first came in no nobody
liked the way he played like he was
really good right so they had to accept
him yeah you know I mean but like he was
pimping homers nobody liked this
changing the code he was changing the
culture right so like for me like that's
what I I love that bro like I grew up
loving that those guys were my favorite
players even though like I would talk to
like my coaches and my coaches would be
like oh he disrespects the game and I
would go and like play in the Little
League game and do the same thing you
know I mean like that's what I was about
like I was about like oh Griffey pinned
the Homer like this I'm gonna try and do
it too like yeah Cano did this I'm gonna
do that too so like that's how I went
around like playing as I grew up and
like nobody ever liked me when I was
playing baseball like the other team
always hated me like because of that
because of that's how I was like I
played loud like in the infield like I
was a shortstop so like I'd like you
know like yeah
she's like throwing balls from under
here at shortstop I was always that guy
ever every time like summer ball it
didn't matter like college Scouts in
there Pro Scouts watching I didn't care
I'll flip the ball from under here in a
showcase it didn't matter like I didn't
care about showing off my arm I just
cared about being flashy so that's how I
was so and that and that do you feel
like that helped you get to where
you are now or do you feel like that
just was an accent I feel like that's an
accident accent yeah because I don't
feel like I mean like it might have
helped me get to where I'm at I mean
maybe because like that's how I play I'm
thinking as that man I think it helped
you because it it's it's what helped you
stay loose yeah like you didn't try and
throw the perfect four seamer like I did
you know saying you were playing more
your style of game yeah I think
it's probably what has gotten you to
where you are now because you're playing
the same game you don't have to try and
all of a sudden now you're trying to
throw it harder or or whatever it is
that you end up changing I feel like you
know that's kind of
you played this you played the same game
your whole life and so now and you were
an infielder and then you moved to the
Outfield yeah take me through that
because that's hard I was an infielder
and I moved to the Outfield no it's hard
Outfield
I think is under it's underrated how
hard it is I feel like nobody
understands how tired something The
Outfield is that's what it really is
like
I feel like you're gonna be able to
enjoy it once you've learned how to play
it but like when you first get out there
from being an infield you're not used to
all that running and you're like bro I
was out there like bro I'm tired am I
the first inning just going from just
going from The Dugout to center field oh
bro I'm back you're doing that 18 times
bro tired tired I'm tired every day I
swear like until like after the All-Star
break when I already got like kind of
used to it
like bro I was like literally running in
like for my bat to lead off the inning
and I was like sure it's the worst thing
ever I think to start off the season I
think the first 25 games of the season I
struck out 20 times in my first step
back because you're tired
and again and as soon as you get in by
the time you get back time you get all
your stuff on if you got a leg guard leg
guard got a bad gloves anything you only
get up there and you're you got a minute
left before minute I'm walking Straight
From The Dugout to the place there you
go like and I'm literally like yeah so
the outfit it's been it's been
something completely different for you
yeah it's like maybe just it's not even
just playing outfit like it's everything
like even to running the bases like if
even if I get on I'm just like tired
yeah I'm not gonna steal this bag right
now I'm gonna hope someone hits one in
the Gap and I can Cruise all the way
around I don't even think my like
numbers around the bases have been like
super fast because I've just been like
just hit it and I'm a jog like yeah I
could stride it out yeah you'll get used
to it you'll get used to it but it's
hard it's hard bro and you're playing
Center you're playing center field and
one of your favorite players you said is
is Griffey right
I think there was a story
no
I'm sorry
that was MJ
there was a story with MJ so we'll
we'll scratch the Griffey I know you
talked to Griffey yeah and he's he's
told you
about staying healthy yeah tell me about
that look before we get to MJ let's
let's tell me about that like when you
talk to him and he told you about that
like what was his what was his words so
I talked to him in spring training uh
actually I talked to him about heading
first okay because I was like
I think I was bending over a little bit
and I was like being a little bit late
on everything and he was like yo you
just got a party out front but then he
was like how do you feel about the
Outfield I was like I mean it's nothing
too crazy and he was like listen like I
know this is your first time going out
there and this is like how I felt when I
first got to the big leagues like
when you see a ball go up and you want
to go get it think about that wall
no like seriously he's like I got
beginning no he's like I got if I didn't
get hurt like let's be real if he didn't
get hurt he'd probably be the best
baseball player ever yep and he got hurt
like in seven seasons and he still hits
600 in some homers so like when you
think of it he was like
when I first got to the big leagues like
and those balls start going up and I
know I can get him even though I know I
had a chance of getting hurt I didn't
care because I just wanted to go get it
don't be me like you know I mean like
don't do that like go out there if you
can catch it standing up and not getting
into a wall that's fine if it goes in
and play it off the wall like me being
me and wanting to be like the best
outfielder ever
like I ain't trying to let nothing hit
off the wall like if I'm gonna catch it
I'm gonna catch it the pride gets in the
way yeah you know what I mean like
that's even like when we go out to the
plate like yeah I could go right here
and take this approach yeah I'm facing
Lefty Lefty I can take this approach hit
a left like a line drive to left field
oh that pitch is right down let me try
and hit it out to right center field you
know so it's just like stuff like that
and do you feel like well I mean I guess
at the time so why why do you
just pure purely Pride just that's why I
wouldn't say it's like Pride it's just
like I see it like you know you out
there
yeah you got to get used to it because
like that's like me in the infield like
when I was in the minor leagues like I
do for everything like nothing was
getting past me like if I could touch it
I don't care if the guy's gonna be safe
at first base I'm stopping everything in
the infield and then when I got to The
Big Field Big League big leagues and
started talking to everybody else like
they're like listen like you don't have
to die for everything save your legs
save your body from all the scratches
and all that bro because like if you
look at my like body row like it's all
scraped up yeah just throwing my body
everywhere from from I was a kid you
know like that's how I learned how to
play it like I used to practice diving
in practice like you know what I mean
like oh yeah you crazy yeah I was
wildling when I was young but I mean you
gotta do what you got to do that's when
I was younger though like I wanted to
make those kind of plays like ESPN every
night and we still do but you just gotta
think about it now yeah now I go into
practice I ain't even trying to get to a
knee yeah I mean like everything
standing up on my feet walking to the
clubhouse Okay so
and then uh you know you have the cup
you're on the cover of the show talk to
Griffey doing these things and now you
have signed with Jordan
when you knew when you had the
opportunity to sign where Jordan
was it like an immediate man yeah I'm
about to sign with Jordan or was it like
I don't know just yet I have a couple of
other opportunities like you know what
what was it for you so for me I was with
Nike right before I was a Jordan so it
was really a hard decision to move from
Nike because Nike started throwing out
some stuff yeah and they took care of
you too and they definitely always took
care of me too but like they started
like
we'll give you this we'll give you that
look at this all right and I was like
yeah it's hard it's hard but I always
want to sign with Jordan and I had like
a little have a little Jordan story for
me yeah I always grew up on and that's
why I always wanted to sign with Jordan
there's people okay tell them about the
story all right so I was 10 years old
uh Michael Jordan had a celebrity
softball game in the Bahamas okay
Atlantis
my stepdad's one of was one of the
umpires of the things so I got to go our
whole Little League was there
this and that Jordan's sneaking out of
the back asking for autograph
he looks at me he turns around and says
one day make me want your autographed
kid and just walks off
like nothing else like he didn't even
budge
just walks off one day make me want your
autograph yeah what'd you have would you
have to I had a picture of them like uh
oh okay Jordan just wanted them to sign
it yeah like that's the only person like
Jeter was there to know the whole
Yankees was there A-Rod CCC okay yeah I
think he brought out some football
players Fitzgerald
uh Ben Roethlisberger was there who he
hit a bomb I'm surprised oh okay that's
why I remember he was there but like
yeah Johnny Damon those guys was there
and I was like hey let me try and you
know get a signature whatever didn't get
he just like turned his back and told me
that and just walked off so like I have
to like go and tell him that because now
that I'm on Jordan yeah he has my
autograph
that's really why I didn't really wanted
it so did do you feel like
do you do you feel like you used that
moment to uh
fuel you and all it's not really the
right word but do you feel like you use
that moment
to now
will it help you get to where you are oh
yeah 100 I think I use that like for my
first got in professional baseball I
told my agent that and he's still my
agent now from I was saying I'm 16 17 to
now he's been my agent and like that was
like one of the main things that we work
to is to get this Jordan deal because
like that's the number one thing I was
one one oh you so you've won even with
when you were with Nike yeah you wanted
to get the Jordan oh yeah okay
and and
when your agent was like Hey you know I
think
I can get you a Jordan or or whatever it
is
what was what went through your mind at
that time I mean so right before we
signed the Nike deal
we were talking to Jordan this is when I
first got to the big league so okay I
had a I think I had an Adidas deal in
the minor leagues I got to the big
leagues we were talking to Jordan
because I only wore Jordan Ones when I
got to the wigglies like even though I
had a dealer still yeah I wore my custom
Jordan ones that I had waiting since the
minor leagues like
I don't think nobody even customized
shoes yet by this time no probably not
like 2019 I mean other than the Jordan
uh the Jordan athletes that people
didn't wear yeah so like I already
customized some painted Jordans waiting
on these to get to the big leagues the
next year I get to the big leagues and I
wear them and I had like three more too
so I wore those the whole year
and then after the season we started
talking to Jordan because they saw it
and they liked it
and they told me like hey sign with like
a one-year deal somewhere else
and then we're gonna try and see what we
could do so then
I end up signing a two-year deal with
Nike instead of one
and that's how it got to where it was at
because it was like after that year with
Nike I was trying to get out of the Nike
deal to go to Jordan but then they like
you know they said yeah I think so I was
like I'll stay another year yeah I mean
like you guys are doing your thing over
here like let me see if you guys are
gonna do it again so then the next year
All-Star game all this stuff and they
were still doing their thing yeah but
then that Jordan deal came through and
that was like yeah you can't compare to
that yeah it was it was like well I mean
and it's been you've enjoyed it so far
yeah you get all the shoes oh yeah oh I
mean you get the customized shoes tell
me like I I just customized some bro
on me for next year oh yeah and I'm
assuming have you gotten on your Zoom
call to customize um my zoom call is
actually tomorrow
okay so are you excited about it oh bro
and you're gonna go through all the what
do you use for inspiration like do you
do you just go through things I love
like I love anime so like anime is gonna
be like one of my shoes next year
and I love like I just like the stuff
that I like to do that I feel like no
like nobody really did yeah like when I
was growing up like anime wasn't a thing
when I was growing up like if you watch
anime you're a nerd back then yeah I was
considered a nerd like I was a baseball
player played basketball football but
then like I would still wear like the
anime hoodies like the anime t-shirts
but everybody still call me a nerd even
though like I was on YouTube yeah but I
just loved it and I didn't care what
people said and like aliens and stuff
like I always yeah I loved it like that
those are the things that I was really
into as a kid and that's what you're
gonna put on your shoes oh yeah anime
and Aliens anime aliens in my family and
me yeah I love myself a lot too so
let's talk about yourself let's talk
being from the Bahamas
do you uh
I was with uh talking to Tristan
McKenzie oh my boy and uh
I think I said it wrong
what's that oh you don't know your own
language that's not my language I speak
English oh
oh so I thought behind behemian he's
Jamaican though it's not this it's
Jamaica they speak Patois yeah I thought
I thought Bahamas did too no oh we just
have an accent you should have asked me
and see you Walling bro I disrespected
all the bahamians out there yeah I
apologize
you know that's why it's actually a
language yeah it'll mean that's what I
thought yeah we don't speak that so you
just speak English accented English yeah
okay
like right now like
this is like to me an American accent
that I'm speaking in so you can
understand me oh so you so you you
change your accent yeah
so can I hear the the Bahamian accent I
mean like right now I could talk to you
like this and this is like my mom my
Bohemian accent right now and then when
you but when you go to American accent
it's like more because like I went to
high school over here yeah I was gonna
ask you a little used to everybody being
like what do you say huh can you repeat
that for me can you please slow down
what you're saying so I just like this
just turned into like a regular thing
for me now like just speaking like this
and you put so you play ball in the
Bahamas right
and came to high school here in Kansas
yeah Wichita schools boarding school
Kansas how was that how was that
it was cool and it was like terrible at
the same time because it was like
Wichita like I don't know what's there
no competition at all so like the
hardest story we had in high school was
like good thing we were a private school
because that like we had Dominicans and
everybody so like our team was kind of
like a cheat code team like in the state
of Kansas when I was growing up we were
like 10th in the state okay okay well we
were a private school so like everybody
didn't really give us like the love that
we were supposed to get until like we're
going to play other private schools and
y'all would beat them and we'll whoop
them but then everybody be like oh they
have Dominicans Venezuelans we had
Japanese kids like bahamians Melting Pot
oh bro ours we had like a thousand kids
in our school and probably only 100
Americans oh wow okay yeah we didn't
have a lot of Americans in our school I
would have never guessed that so and a
lot of you guys did a lot of you guys
get recruited to play baseball uh it
depends what you did like soccer we had
all the Mexicans the kids from Spain the
kids from like Slovakia yeah like yeah
yeah and everything basketball was
straight European yeah you played
basketball how like did you not want to
play basketball I love that I was short
yeah I was only like when I was in high
school like I was 16 and as a senior so
like oh you're 16 as a senior yeah oh so
you're young okay I was super young but
at baseball I was just raw like I was
still hitting homers in baseball but
like me I was just like Rim grazing
dunks like I was just starting to dunk
and like I was starting to shoot a
little bit better I could also I could
handle the ball really well and I was
like best thing passing like yeah I'll
make long passes because I was a
baseball player so like the passing was
the easiest part for me and driving to
the rim and I just like got my first
body and like I see it was a scene
off a free throw okay so like it was
just like a lot of things was coming
together and like schools were starting
to recruit me and for basketball yeah
basketball and football same football
yeah tell me about yeah safety so you
didn't play offense no just I was a wide
receiver but I didn't after I got
concussion as a junior oh you got hit
yeah I got hit too hard and that was the
last time I played
freshman the junior no tell me about
that place then when I got hit yeah uh
so
I was like from my freshman year to my
junior year I was playing great like
just running past everybody like that's
fast like nobody could touch me like
this big kid that they're like oh yeah
he's like number four in the state
corner corner okay but he was big he was
like six three two twenty he ran like a
four five forty like he was flying like
we were the same speed so like I'm
coming off this like I'm in playing the
slot coming off the slant
up the middle and he's on the other side
because he's playing against our six
foot one okay like our big wide receiver
he's like number 10 in the state okay
and
I come across
and I catch it and I see him and I'm
like oh yeah I'm gonna just cross this
dude right up I'm gonna fake I'm gonna
fake in this way and go middle right so
I catch it and I go to fake to go around
him and go to cut to the middle and this
dude literally there's lit my days like
he literally knew I was gonna do that
like he looked like he just read the
play perfectly like he saw me fake he
didn't even budge it this way he
literally went the other way and just
straight head down and it hurt hurt bro
I was out I was out for like a week and
a half two weeks bro I didn't want to
play no more no I was in a crier it was
more like a moaner like oh you know like
I was the boner I was like so so did you
lay there for a little bit oh bruh oh
they had to come get you yes like come
get me I'm not standing up right now
like I'm gonna wave to the crowd like
I'm okay and when you you tell you and
then did you play football your senior
Year too yeah I think you played
football basketball and baseball all
four years yeah and then you got recruit
uh you signed yeah baseball yeah what
made you want to sign baseball instead
of playing football or basketball well
the football part I was really good at
football and I really wanted to actually
go to college and play football and
baseball
but I was really like baseball is always
my number one thing okay and football
hurt yeah so like that was the main
thing for me and like Scouts for
basketball was more like I need to grow
a little bit more okay so like that was
out of the window like I was good but
like I need to grow and I had to work a
little bit harder and I didn't want to
do all that and like that was my dad's
game my dad was a basketball player so I
played it for him you know what I mean
but like football it was my uncle's game
and like me and my uncle were closer in
a way we like grew up as brothers
and like that's what I played a little
bit with him and baseball but it was
just like baseball and football were my
two favorites but then like after that
hit bro I was like yeah
unless I'm playing defense you know I
ain't trying to play okay so you signed
as a free agent signed with the the
Marlins I'm down back I'm sorry
and then you play
hot how long did you play in the minor
leagues
how many seasons yeah three seasons I
think three seasons did you enjoy it
one I think I only enjoyed one year in
the minor leagues
why why why was it only one year uh
my first year
I played no I got hurt so all my friends
like that I got that I signed with they
were gone they were gone and like the
people that I like I'm not gonna lie
like in the Marlies I thought it was so
like
easy like I was the guys that I was
playing with after my guys left like
when your group leaves you you know what
I mean like because you're hurt you got
to repeat here
like I was like dang like you're trying
to say they're better than me like this
thing like I don't deserve to be here
like and so you use that to you oh yeah
it's like 20 homers 20 homers yeah big
leagues and so
you got traded from the Diamondbacks to
the Marlins and when you got traded how
did you feel
it felt awkward but I could tell like
the organization was getting rid of my
group if that makes sense of guys yeah
because I like we saw them started to
like sign the guys that was in front of
us for an extension
and then like because our group was like
my team was the number one Prospect I
was the number one Prospect the number
two Prospect was our catcher the number
three Prospect was our first baseman
number four Prospect was our starting
pitcher number five was our center
fielder number six was our third baseman
oh your whole team our whole team like
number 16 17 12 21 20 yeah we won we won
like we won every year it was like it
wasn't like we were going up there and
just like losing games like I know you
were winning bro playoffs everything was
sick okay so you know what I mean
and so that that I'm assuming was the
fun oh that was the fun yeah like when I
after that first year when they left me
and I had to go and play that year by
myself
and I was like man this is a boring like
I have nobody doing celebrations with me
I have nothing to do like you know
forever yeah you know I mean like me and
my like I had a celebration with
everybody like going straight through
the Dugout like even when we hit homers
everybody had their own celebrations
going around the bases I even had like
the most boring people on our team
was doing celebrations going around the
basement oh okay because I told him I
was like no we having fun we're going to
enjoy this and we enjoyed every like we
won the first half in double A
by like 25 games uh okay and y'all are
having fun doing having fun I bet them I
bet other teams were hating they hated
us like cuz like you couldn't do
anything against us yeah it was like one
through nine had 20 to 30 homers I let
our team in homers every year
okay that's crazy so you had fun so all
in all you kind of you really enjoy the
money yeah once you made it to to my
boys to my boys and then we got traded
off okay so
and then you made it to the big leagues
and now you have
um doing things with your boys obviously
on the on the field Homer and
celebrations and all these type of
things but you also do a lot of things
off the field like fashion shows oh yeah
you know you have your foundation tell
me about that like how how is it
um having the foundation in the Bahamas
and doing the fashion shows and doing
doing these things like what what drives
you to do that
I mean
now that I've made it to the big leagues
it just shows me that I could do really
whatever I want to do whatever I put my
mind to I could really do that so like
when I first got to the big leagues I
asked my agent I was like Hey I want to
put a foundation together for kids in
the Bahamas and if we can make it to
South Miami or South Florida let's do
that too but I want to make a foundation
for kids that had it hard like how I
have it had it coming up like I want to
make it easier for them
and and like everybody knows like my
passion is fashion like I love fashion
like I love getting dressed I love
opening I love putting things together I
like mixing colors I like to try and do
a lot of crazy stuff so he was like
let's so we were having the opening this
year's like four years in the making the
opening event this year just passed last
week and he was like hey
what do you want to do at your opening
event you could do anything you want we
could do auction this and that and I was
like let's do a fashion show like I want
to be able to walk down like me and my
girl walk down as a fashion like let me
put a couple outfits together put a
couple people in a couple outfits and
let's do it and he was like bro that
sounds sick like we could do that and I
was like bet let's get it going so then
like when he got it going we we did the
auction too yeah you did both mixed them
yeah but like the fashion show was so
sick especially you see like
the stuff that the people were wearing
because they're my stuff that I kind of
I put the outfits together in a way so
they were kind of sick and so who who
who was the best dress me
I ain't gonna make nobody dress better
than me you know I mean come on okay so
when when wearing an outfit
putting on an outfit right I feel like
over half of it is just pure confidence
75 75 is okay it's just pure confidence
in whatever you feel like whatever
you're wearing looks good so what
happens when you that that 25 25 is like
ah Jazz it really don't look that good
but because you're so confident it looks
good like how how do you get that much
confidence in what you're wearing I mean
you gotta like it though like you got to
be able to say you don't feel like you
could put something on that you don't
like yeah if I don't like it I ain't
gonna wear it
um
like I mean don't get me wrong if I have
to wear it in a fashion show I I can
definitely stir the confidence together
I gotta look in the mirror a couple
times try to like fix it this way fix it
that way you know I'm trying to say like
make it work but like if I'm just going
let's say we're going out or I'm coming
here right my girl already told me she
was like bro you're a fit does not look
like good like what I'm in right now she
said she was like I was like wait let me
let me fix it up a little bit because I
was only like in the shirt and pants
nothing else like no shoes no nothing so
I come back in the shoes and she's like
okay and I came back and she was like
you know like these these are fresh on
like you know what I'm saying like I
came back oh you turned it on okay
put on a couple of chains put on the
bracelets and I'm like how are you going
like is it good yet put on the watch put
on the glasses turn on the hat and then
we go like okay like something like look
at me now like are we doing something
and she'd be like oh yeah you actually
turn that whole fit to around you know I
mean like so like the accessories you
need accessories too you're you got to
be an accessory guy I mean I mean I like
accessories I don't need them I would
say that I could go down a fashion show
without accessory without accessories
yeah but except I feel like I'm the
accessory you are the accessory yeah
they see that's how you got to wear your
stuff because like once you put it on
you got to have the confidence to say I
make it look better not just this would
make it look better or this would make
it look better like whatever I put
together with this
is what makes it look better and so do
you have you thought about like teaching
classes for for fashion yeah like I mean
some of my teammates need it I ain't
gonna lie yeah my teammates do need that
you know teach the boys show the boys I
mean I mean every time I walk in the
clubhouse they do be like yo cheers
oh Cheers Cheers that's the it's not
Jazz Rock I thought they called you Jazz
you're gonna call me I can't use my
government name man oh okay come on
my thing it doesn't even say it just
says Jazz no it's just [__] [__] oh jazz
jazz okay okay yeah so so but
what else do you do you do I know I
talked to yinci Almonte he was telling
me about you guys do like a home run
derby down there yeah
and that's is that a charity event home
yes it is tell me about that tell me
about that because I want to go to that
I want to bring my wife to that oh yeah
and I feel like that would be that would
be super dope to come and and support
you you know and you know have fun it's
a great experience with the boys
especially for the boys tell me about it
tell me about it so we do the foundation
at home we do like these camps for kids
uh because this is the only time that we
bring down big Leaguers like we have Dom
Smith yes he comes tukey we try to teach
the kids like hey like this is the
fundamentals of baseball bring them
around a couple big Leaguers just try to
make their dreams come true for like
this this week right
and we do all these events we'll do a
celebrity softball game we do all and
the kids are invited to everything okay
right they come to everything except
like now that we're done with the kids
like let's say we have the kids camp
that day and we're done with that now
it's time for us to hang out as big
Leaguers and we just go and hang out
talk bring the wives everybody's just
around and just enjoying the Bahamas we
take you guys on like
just rides around the city we we show
you places that we live and like the
hoods that we're from and show you all
these stuff go on boat rides we have a
little pirate ship that we take you guys
on and all stuff like that and but then
we also give back to the to the
foundations of like the Breast Cancer
Foundation because one of the guys
taught Isaac's his grandma passed from
breast cancer I have a couple aunts that
die from breast cancer so we try to give
back to Breast Cancer Foundation in the
Bahamas and we also give back to the
foundation for the the
it's for the kids it's for the Lesser
kids right so we all and we give back to
all the little leagues of the Bahamas so
we do all of that and it's just like the
end of the experience is the Home Run
Derby where you hit the balls in the
water oh yeah so you come back with your
custom bag your custom shoes and you
just come and enjoy it bro it's like
it's like a party every day that sounds
like that I really do want to be a part
of that man so whenever you get all the
details and all that stuff yeah I'll
shoot it send it over to me and me and
the wife will be there let's go back to
Fashion one more time
who would you say can you give me like a
top five of guys in the league now who
you feel like are
fashionable or whatever okay got some
swag got the most swag all right me at
number one okay
uh I would say that
he's a cheat code because he's from
Japan okay you Darvis have you seen your
Darvis I've only seen him in the in the
in the swag they go Brown
you haven't seen him in like the swag
cam when they're walking into the field
oh man I don't even be looking at the at
the at the monitor for the most well I
mean I've seen a couple of his pictures
though that got him off the field yep
and it's
he got the Japanese swag bro it's so
it's unfair because he gets everything
from Japan so like everything for him is
literally already coming like okay you
know what I mean like okay so you got
that's two okay I think uh if we're
talking on the field no no no no no on
and off no we're just from an off the
field okay Blake Snell snail three snow
he's got a big shoe collection too oh
yeah
snow has a little bit of Swag I would
say
off the field off the field
thing I don't know much off the field
swag guys but except like I'd be paying
attention to some people's pictures and
I'd be like okay that dude he got it
like that guy got it like I feel like
you have swag but that's because you're
a Jordan guy and you wear what it like
you have so much confidence in what you
wear like you can walk out with that and
still be more Swagger than most guys in
the league that's just because that's 75
percent uh exactly confidence exactly I
feel like I can put on whatever it
doesn't matter exactly see you're one of
those guys though I mean like like Acuna
is one of those guys too yeah being in
La being being in L.A
when I was in Boston I didn't have no I
remember you in Boston yeah you look
like you were 12. yeah exactly that's
crazy yeah and
where I'm from like there was plenty of
people with swag but like that just
wasn't in my household you know saying
like my mom my mom would go get my
clothes at yard sales like her thing was
me too okay so but my mom
she wasn't really she she knows how to
dress for her not for everybody else not
for me you know what I'm saying like she
was getting me the Tommy Hilfiger polos
oh yeah I can show you a Tommy Hilfiger
photo pick after this yeah I'll tell you
I was rocking that yeah yeah I didn't
have it I didn't have it blue and white
stripes it took me a minute to see my
mom was ironing my jeans with the crease
yeah I had the crease in the middle yeah
so that's our time
yeah but that wasn't swag though what
you mean it's not not for me for me for
me because you felt like people people
in school when they had a creek oh yeah
I was wearing Jordans you know what I'm
saying and at the time George
I wore George they was fry me for George
for real yeah and so
but I had to rock them
with the creep I mean man I ain't have I
didn't have Jordans and stuff I wasn't
wearing I wear Jordans like when I hoped
but like going to school now I would
have probably some Tommy's or some I
ain't had like case K-Swiss I didn't no
I don't even know what I had yard sale
shoes you know what I'm saying and it
wasn't like
she didn't get them
they wouldn't they didn't have my size
at that yard sale
you know what I'm saying so but anyways
you know my mom she definitely sorry Ma
I ain't trying she did what she had to
do she did what she had to do you know
what I'm saying and now now you know
being in La the has definitely given me
the confidence and the swag so you said
you were number one yeah
you Darvish Blake snail yeah I give it
to you and then Acuna what about like
Lindor
all right he's all right okay yeah he
has the confidence though he definitely
has the confidence and you know
bruised our graterol on our team yeah
he's swaggy I haven't seen that take out
Miguel Rojas oh yeah I remember we had
some Miro has some Swag yeah he does
have some swag they do have some there
are a lot of guys and you're you're on
Tick Tock too right what do you like do
you you do all the little I be boredom
so I'd be like just posting random stuff
like you know the little game you do the
outfit oh oh I'll be doing all that no
no I just do the things like where they
do the little rings and the like card
games
like it'd just be like random things on
Tick Tock like card games and stuff like
trying to beat like a little stage or
something like that's the stuff I do I'd
be bored I'd be laughing okay and I got
one more question for you before we get
to the fan questions okay how many
tattoos you got
um
I got a count don't even worry about
this how many hours of tattoos do you
have Bingo that makes more sense so I
would say
maybe 50 50 hours I don't even know if
that's a ladder but I have not I mean
because if you think of it every tattoo
is like on me at least I do a lot of all
my tattoos are big okay like this arm
alone is one tattoo okay okay they're
not multiple and this was like four
hours so when you what are your
Inspirations this was like me hitting
like I just loved all of these pictures
of me hitting so I did it and I wanted
to make like a background story behind
it but I haven't got to that yet you
will okay and this is like my Grandma's
favorite Bible verse this is like
a star in the island that I'm from is in
it Nassau in the Bahamas this is a
compass because you know like everybody
thinks of Bahamas and they think of like
compass and directions when we're in
Bahamas
uh I'm an Aquarius and I love like water
so like this is like a trident for the
water and all that stuff area code of
the Bahamas
uh a lion this is actually my first this
is a lion with a crown on it
with my grandma always calls me a beast
and I'm sure yeah I'm a little prince so
I put up you know me and my grandma are
really close so I do a lot of things for
my grandma and these are like my
favorite anime series and then me and my
little brother has this tattoo so is
Anime is Dragon Ball Z anime yes it
really is because I did not like anime
too then yes there it is that's my dad's
favorite anime so like that's what I'm
saying like people didn't really know
what anime was until like you had to
explain it to him like Dragon Ball Z is
like one of the first like big animes
ever you know I mean so like
I love Dragon Ball Z my dad my uncles
love it but they always call me a nerd
for watching like Naruto which was my
talking like yeah this started the year
I was born like you know I mean like
okay yeah so it's like weird nice okay
all right so now I got some fan
questions for you oh
what's your favorite Stadium to play in
oh I got I got a couple all right let's
hear it so my number one favorite
Stadium to play in is la oh nice okay
because I hit homers there like it's so
great hitting there this freaking back
like that was my like first time
actually being there for a series
instead of just playing one game and
leaving uh-huh
but the background bro it's pitch black
yeah like the ball looks like this oh
okay oh my God I love playing there yeah
okay so what okay let's go with your
least favorite place what's your least
favorite oh man um
my least favorite place
jeez I haven't played in Kansas City yet
but I'm sure I'm gonna hate it there
really yeah there's no way Kansas City
is worse than Oakland I've never played
there either oh my gosh you've never
played in Oakland no
okay
well then you can't answer that question
I can't answer the question because I
haven't played anything in or Kansas
City Kansas City is much much nicer than
Oakland oh yeah I've heard Oakland is
terrible yeah you'll see it you'll see
it it's unexplainable it's really
unexplained is it like a minor league
field
yeah I'll let you find out yourself
I got another question all right so
what's your favorite cleats what's your
favorite pair of cleats you've worn in
the game
oh
um The Mother's Day 11s that we had this
year those were nice those are nice
those or the fives
okay the Jackie Robinson yeah okay I
ain't thinking about those yeah yeah
those are nasty but you out of all the
ones you customized no no my ice cream
cleats are the dope is oh the ice cream
ones yeah the ice cream ones are dope I
haven't even seen those I I've heard
about them though somebody told me jazz
ah those those I've seen those I saw
those on Instagram I didn't know they
were yours so what what was the
inspiration about though did you
customize those or what did you buy
those and put cleats on the bottom what
what no that's the ones that Jordan made
for me oh you made those with Jordan I
didn't know that those are my pe's
those are the pe's from this year yeah I
got some alien ones so those are your
favorite ones yeah those are swag those
are different those are hard I didn't
know that I didn't know that you I
thought you uh like had them had someone
paint them or something and then put
cleats oh nah so the inspiration behind
that is you know I started my glove
company
the gloves that I wore the batting
gloves no the gloves I didn't know you
started so yeah nothing so my glove
company Arya with the ice cream gloves
and oh okay I've seen the glasses
I'm a owner in the company right and we
started last year and
I wanted to have my own line
so I started ice cream like because I
love ice cream like my favorite ice
cream cookies and cream you start off
with the black and white right the black
glove with the i the white ice cream
couldn't wear it and it'll be bands it
oh wow so I came out with a blue one
I wanted to come out with the pink one
but the pink gloves weren't ready yet
and I didn't like the leather on the
pink ones yet so I didn't use it until
this year where we got the Japanese kilt
on it like the real good Japanese
leather on it so when I did that
with the Japanese leather
like it made the glove like perfect
so this year I told them Jordan last
year I thought I was like I want some
strawberry ice cream
like cleats and I want the cleats to
look like a waffle cone because that's
the way my glove looks
so then when we put it all together and
it came out the glove and the cleats
just came out perfectly so are you gonna
do this every year with the ice cream
and everything I mean well at this point
you need to that's just the ice cream at
least one ice cream pair
uh I can actually there's so many
flavors of ice cream you might as well
no but like then I want to do different
stuff for different kids like kids want
to come out and they want to try like
not every kid likes ice cream like kids
like anime so like
I'm gonna next year I have some I might
have a pair of anime cleats that go with
my glove
because whatever Jordan does with the
cleats
I can go and good thing about my glove
company is that I'm being an owner in it
we're actually connected to a lot of the
people that create the animated in Japan
so like I already got a deal with these
guys
for my glove like we sold them at the
All-Star game last year
so you gotta you got a bunch of stuff
coming up too oh bro it's about to be so
your Instagram about to be popping I
mean with ice cream or not ice cream
anime you're gonna have everything
everything I have a banana glove
okay all right okay so I do I'm I'm
excited to see you ain't got to talk I'm
just excited to see it I'm excited I'll
show you it at the field yeah please I
got another question who's the most
clutch Pro in Miami right now
most clutch Pro so there probably
in Miami oh in Miami just fully Miami
well the heat loss
okay so is that that just cancel out but
I mean Jimmy is Jimmy buckets yeah he's
Jimmy buckets but like we gotta wait
until this season ends because we
haven't even got to the playoffs yet
yeah okay so there's some more athletes
here so we got Solaire me ariah's if you
got De La Cruz you got Burger Bell we
got all these people right now that
could actually prove themselves but you
know the most clutch in all of Miami
right now right now when's the last time
Miami won a championship it didn't got
to be it doesn't have to be about the
Marlins but that's what I'm trying to
say who's gonna win like okay there's a
man here there's a man that just got
here that you try to say you no not me
oh let's see oh my God I forgot yes I
forgot the man that just got here I
forgot Messi have you gotten have you
gotten to watch it watch it at all watch
it in person okay we've been watching in
the clubhouses so I I remember them
winning the championship and I forgot so
shout out messy tip my cat to you so you
are the most clutch for right now for
right now yeah we got the we gotta
playoff baseball coming up in October
we'll see yeah I mean I'm with you I'm
with you I was just I was just saying
like you know that
I would say he's the most clutch in his
sport for sure yeah for sure for sure
like he's the best player in the sport I
would say Okay so
what's your top three animes then what's
what's your top three anime oh number
one last question is One Piece One One
Piece is number one I normally wear the
chain but I'm not wearing the chain
today one piece yeah and that's a that's
a sh like that's a anime okay yeah like
I feel like one piece is like more like
how I grew up in a way like just chasing
your dream and not worrying about the
way anything faces you you just keep on
going and push through it and just keep
on believing in your dream it's gonna
happen Okay that's what one piece is
really about okay
number two is Naruto which is tattooed
on my leg
uh uh number three he said right now so
I would say probably Black Clover
would be my number three if they would
make more episodes right now is there so
it does anime does it have like a
channel on TV
it's like Netflix oh it's on Netflix you
just go on Netflix I mean it's on
Netflix or you could go online I ain't
know who's on like Nickelodeon or
something like you know we have to used
to have to watch they can't you can't
watch anime on Nickelodeon it's really
too explicit for that I don't even
remember where we used to watch Dragon
Ball Z what do we used to watch Dragon
Ball Z on Adult Swim Adult Swim got it
because anime isn't really
for kids it's not a cartoon it's not
really it's a cartoon for adults adults
yeah it's not for kids because they'd be
cussing and all that yeah yeah I didn't
know that it's not a kid's show I mean
well I I I see so it's really for teens
I may get into it if they if they
re-release Dragon Ball they have they
just did well then I'm probably not
gonna get into it what because I would
have known about it if I would you know
I feel like you should have known about
it you just didn't pay attention to it
probably but now I got kids and ah it's
just hard to I ain't got no kids yeah
you got time to watch TV yeah I'd be
watching TV all day yeah so all right
brother well thank thanks for uh coming
on the show man
um I do want to give you a big shout out
for always being you not caring about
what other people have to say I think a
lot of us
can learn from that and um can use that
in our life because you know people
worry about what other people say so
much that we let what other people say
kind of run our own lives and you don't
allow that so thank you for being a
perfect example perfect example for that
also make sure you stop running into the
wall brother oh yeah that ain't
happening no more no more walls
um
so we can so you can stay healthy and be
who you want to be and I do want to give
you one last shout out and I want to
thank you for telling me about
this dolphin thing because I'm never
going to swim with dolphins
no uh you know they you scared me you
messed it up what so whatever Resort
sorry guys don't ask me to swim with
dolphins I'm not going to just take your
chain off
nah even if I take it off man uh you you
said they just you know they got it you
know I always and I swam with dolphins
once and it scared me and that was fine
everything was fine so I'm swimming the
pigs you know during during the trip you
know the pigs you change your mind I'm
I'm going with the pigs yeah I'm going
the Pigs we're going to be in the pig
style in the uh in the water so anyways
uh thank you guys for joining Jazz
thanks for coming on brother and uh we
will see Jazz Euro stepping at home
plate at some point catch you guys later
on
[Music]